welcome back to spectrum this is a super
highly requested episode so we hope he
does enjoy please stick around after
sowed for a special offer from our
sponsor - lame but first here's the
episode I don't believe in the Bible God
because he's he's an a-hole but I
believe that in the universe somewhere
even those a lot of evidence there's
nothing out there there could be another
dimension
we don't know we've probably all had the
experience of some older person saying
oh well when you're on your deathbed I'm
sure you'll you'll believe you'll want
Jesus or something and no like I'm just
I'm happy I'm content
I'm excited about my beliefs I'm open to
ideas that can fit within a reasonable
framework but no spiritual or
supernatural idea has ever fit that
standard like I'm open to that's why I'm
like I'm that weird category of agnostic
a this atheism like you were like what's
that how can you be an agnostic and
atheist that's weird
you're contradicting yourself but I'm
open to it I don't believe in the Bible
God because he's he's an a-hole but I
believe that in the universe somewhere
even those a lot of evidence that
there's no thing out there there could
be another dimension there could be like
black holes like interstellar could go
somewhere yeah we don't know for me you
know I'm open to Wiccan ISM and paganism
you know it's a fun little thing to do
see what happens I think you can be
atheist and spiritual too you can have
different beliefs I've had some crazy
Ouija board experiences I believe in
something else I don't believe in
someone else I believe as above so below
I think everything is very connected and
I believe that I should behave in a way
that I would want acted towards back to
me and I think that's a very spiritual
idea you know
the energy is recycled and that our
actions invite actions he's a waste of
time prayer is people argue very often
to me that prayer brings a lot of
comfort and has meaning to them you know
why it has to be that over all of the
other options you can do I don't know
and and and when considering that in a
lot of cases you're choosing to step
back you're choosing to remove your
responsibility from any situation yeah I
have issues with that
nothing aggravates me more - especially
like our current political climate and
what a group of people is gunned down
and our public and politician tweets out
like sending thoughts and prayers but at
the same time I'm on the somewhat
disagree side because I personally think
praying will not accomplish anything but
I think that what someone has to do to
put positive energy out into their life
and start their day and I know that my
parents pray for me every night and it
it makes me happy but I think like
they're sending out positive thoughts
[Music]
three two that was went into Catholicism
I was born into a Catholic family I
think the majority of of religion is
indoctrination of children it's just by
happenstance of where you're born what
religion you're born into and who your
parents happen to be I grew up in a very
quintessential Jewish household but I
did go on birthright when I was 18 and I
think that was a big factor in my
atheism because while I was on that trip
I asked a lot of questions which I think
you're supposed to do to get out of it
and all I could think about was how if I
was a couple miles over I might be
praying to Allah instead of Hashem I
couldn't find a difference in my god
versus another God or justification for
why my god it was more likely of
existing than another God for me growing
up Mormon it was just really oppressive
it was basically your life in your whole
identity and everyone that you even had
to just hang out with or just be around
was Mormon you don't have a choice
basically it's it's been a struggle for
me I left when I was 18 years old I
wouldn't have it any other way
honestly because I just I do not like to
believe in a lie Mormonism is a lie and
it's a fraud yeah I I think we're very
close I'm like the same spectrum but I
grew up born and raised a Jehovah's
Witness believing I believe in that
Jehovah was God believing that you know
Armageddon was gonna come and if you
weren't a Jehovah's Witness and we
didn't convert everyone else did you
know whose witnesses they were gonna die
we believe this way no holidays no
birthdays no no Christmas no blood
transfusions like thousands of people
have died danger of some of these
beliefs for no reason I know many people
have died and and they shouldn't have
this is for no reason but
I'm glad that I'm out because it's
really scary but super religious and
once I was out it was like a relief from
my shoulders because part of me when I
got this fellowship was like oh [ __ ] you
know my life is ending you lose your
family you lose your support system
every when it takes you out you're
you're you're dead it was it was nice to
believe that we were scammed and we were
lied to
we deserve better can I know I mean all
anyone has to do is just research just
look just we just go out there and see
the harms their religion not inherently
does but that it can and therefore does
and any major issue you can take in the
in the US and somehow religion will find
a way to be behind that the reason why
I'm setting here despite being hurt by
what religion in the past is that I feel
like religion brings a lot of good to
just like the world in general the pros
outweigh the cons in my view if there
are people out there who feel like they
need an instruction manual to be a good
person I think they should have it the
more I've thought about it I've kind of
looked at maybe large institutions power
structures dogmatic beliefs are maybe
more the real problem than the really
broad big unwieldy definition of
religion the community I run is called
atheist united most people in my
community would love to destroy religion
in the world and think the world will
suddenly be better but I see a bunch of
atheists then that are struggling with
the same exact problems that still have
the same prejudices the same deal with
the same stereotypes and we just changed
the label I do agree that there is
community that's brought by religion but
wherever there's community there
someone outside of that community there
are people not accepted into that
community there's ostracism but I think
in a world where there is either no
religion or multitude of religions
there's always going to be like division
in that multitude and I just don't know
if the ostracism and the pain is worth
the hope that the community will
override that just to push back a little
bit given that we are tribal animals
right we do get together you know if
it's not going to be religions which I'm
fine with
then it's maybe your soccer team or your
chess club or your sorority and my
biggest concern and why I work in this
community is I I don't know if you want
to raise your children necessarily there
or if you feel like they share your
values enough to help you if you're in
the hospital or you know they're the
people you can turn to if you're on your
deathbed well just push back a little
bit to I think that there is an issue if
you think that the only group of Solus
that you can find for deep existential
or physical problems is your religious
group if they are the only people that
you can turn to for help then that's a
problem because then you're feel trapped
inside of them but you can't escape that
kind of group and you touched on that a
lot having different groups with
different opinions instead of one group
that has one fundamental idea and sense
of morality you need a group that can
check that morality
in a higher breed two one
I don't think it would make my life
easier I would have all the same
questions I have and have worse answers
I think it'd be very comforting to
believe in a higher power to believe
that no matter what happens you'll be ok
I think I'd be a much happier person but
I'm also very proud of what I have
accomplished on my own I know everything
that I have achieved is through my own
effort last year someone that I used to
be very close with died of an opioid
addiction and it was like rattled my
world because I'd never really been
faced with the idea that like like it
you always know like you're gonna die
one day and people die and it happens
but it just it was like this like
visceral reaction that we are so
immortal and we are so powerless and it
really messed me up and sometimes I
still like wake up at night and I'm like
I have to drink a lot of water and relax
I'm so terrified of the idea of not
existent anymore it's not the idea of
dying it's the idea of nothing
[Music]
I can't be a hypocrite and say I would
do the exact same thing I know religion
and the religious have done to me and
others hearing all of you and say you're
disowned you're no longer welcome in my
home you you are no longer a part of my
life I can't do that and so therefore
I'm going to change my answer to this
your own relationship with God is very
personal so Who am I to say who you
should believe in or what you should
believe in as long as you're not hurting
anybody or yourself whatever is in your
heart just do it as long as you're not
hurting anybody would I be upset if my
child believed in a god a little bit I'm
not gonna lie every like damn I didn't
do a good job but I'd like it I agree
with a lot of your guys's points like as
long as it's not hurting people as long
as you're like pursuing your happiness
be yourself be happy whatever that looks
like
I have something my problem with a
religious person has never been their
religion it has been like things that
they have used that religion to justify
reputation of it yeah or actions or
behaviors in name of their God you know
so if my child chooses to believe in God
and they don't use that justify harm or
malice and that's fine yeah and one
person I really look up to who is kind
of christ-like is mr. Rogers he's always
been gentle and nice you know and he
believes in God Who am I to say hey mr.
Rogers you need to stop
[Applause]
yeah you guys someone do lunch I really
enjoyed that discussion yeah absolutely
it was really interesting to hear that
some of these atheists are still open to
spiritual ideas definitely a big thank
you to - Lannon for supporting this
episode and for making our content
possible for those of you who don't know
- Lane is awesome it securely generates
and stores all of your password
information across every device so you
never have to click a lost password
again you can start your passport info
your Wi-Fi info your banking info and
even autos those are credit cards so you
never have to go searching through your
wallet which is super great for travel
yeah and speaking of travel there's also
a VPN so you won't be tracked and you
can access content while browsing the
Internet in other countries so for all
you good humans out there make sure you
go to - Lang comm / DubLi to get - Lane
free on your first device and make sure
you use a code Jubilee when you're ready
to upgrade to premium and get 10% off
make sure to LIKE comment subscribe and
we'll see you next time